bir
de günaydın diyorum ev burada olmak çok
kıymetli özellikle Siz gençlerle
konuşmak çok kıymetli Benim de 18
yaşında bir oğlum var bir de o beş
yaşında bir kızım var o yüzden böyle
pırıl pırıl bakan gözlere bayılıyorum
heyecanlıyım bu kırmızılı ha kadar
heyecanlı bir şey var Birçok anlaşılacak
canlı yayınlara devam et çıkıyorum ama
başka bir şeyimiz şimdi söylemek
istiyorum hayal kuruyor birkaç soru
sormak istiyorum Yani şimdi buraya gelen
iki konuşmacı da aynı şeyi hep uyguluyor
hayal kuruyor musunuz Bir hayaliniz var
mı Yani sizi heyecanlandıran böyle
kalbinizi çarptıran ya da mesela ben
hayalimi 40 yaşında kavuştum desem Of o
kadar bekleyeceğim ben full benim daha
iyi mi dersiniz yoksa yok 40 da fena
değilmiş yani en azından bulmuş mı yoksa
70'e kadar yolu var dersiniz bilmiyorum
ama ben hatta biz bunu daha var Hayaller
birleşirmi Yani birkaç ay ay kurarsanız
o ayarlar el ele tutuşur sonra sizin
önünüze böyle bir hediye gibi kucağınıza
düşer mi Bir de bunu düşünüyorum yani
tek ayarladık almaya bir sürü hayal
kururü ama ben hayalmi kurdum acaba da
bu olay bu bilinçli yapılan bir şey
değil hani Herkes diyor içinizdekini
bulun çıkartın diye elbet çıkıyor mesela
ben sizin yaşınızdayken kaç yaşındayken
işte ondan 12'den sonra şu tiyatro
ağaçları bayılıyorum tiyatroya gitmeye
fakat tiyatrodan çıkıyorum o kadar mutlu
oluyorum ağlayacağım bir Ağlama
istediğim niye Neden ben bu koltukta
oturuyorum sahnede değilim diye yani
böyle bir değişik bir sizden niye
sahnede ben bu koltukta diye oturuyor
niye sahnede değil hep bunun
sorguluyorum ve 18 yaşıma geldim
üniversite zamanı Bu üniversite sınavına
girdim Boğaziçi Uluslararası ilişkilere
kat artık bazı Turizm Otelcilik kazandım
Evet ve aynı zamanda da konservatuar
sınavına girdim Yıldız Kenter ciri
Selçuk Yöntem yüreği 300 kişi içinden 15
kişi içine girdim sonra 10 kişi
seçilecek orada eğlendim ob eskisi
içinde gittim Yıldız Kenter Hoca dedi ki
Allah rahmet eylesin Özge biz seni çok
beğendik Bir sene daha çalış sen niye
seni alacağım dedi ama çok moralim
bozuldu ve ailem dedi ki Özge Boğaziçi
Üniversitesi'ni kazandı Sonuçta hayat
seni bekliyor boş ver dediler Hadi okula
git ben de okula gittim Sonra zaten iki
senelik bölümümüz O zaman iki senede
96'da mezun oldu bir staja girdim hemen
kısaca girdiğin yerden iş teklifi geldi
iş hayatı öyle bir şeydi zaten bir anda
oraya kanalize oluyorsunuz tiyatroyu
koyduk önüme hep bi
o ve gönlüme hayata devam ettim sonra
divan Oteli'nde çalıştım Hilton
Oteli'nde sahip Beş Yıldızlı otellerde
ama alanı yiyecek içecek sektörü Çünkü
aslında Turizm Otelcilik ligasyonu bir
okuyorsunuz odanı bayılıyorum menüler
yapıyorum davetler Yapıyorum işte Çok
keyif alıyorum ama Mutfağı inerken böyle
biraz çekiliyorum türküsü yani kaç
kişiye yemek güzelde mutfaklar acayip
Soğan kokusu var indiğiniz zaman 10 tane
soğan solmuş gibi oluyorsunuz biraz
kaçıyorum yani menü veriyorum hemen
kaçamak soğan korkuyorum diye Halbuki
şimdiki aklım olsa o mutfakta gece
gündüz sabah hiç çıkmam çünkü büyük bir
eğitim Aslında orası ama o zaman ki
kapat Böyle çalışıyoruz Ee sonra işte bu
otellerde çalışan 2010'da evlendi
evlenince o tatil çok zor bir meslek
Turkcell'e geçtim ve orada altı sene
kurumsal da yine bu organizasyon menüler
ve bunları uğraştım çocuklar büyüyünce
Grup hayattan çıktım o zaman da
e-ticaret sitesi çok popüler e-ticaret
yani yiyorlar gümbür gümbür şansı kadın
nokta com gibi e-ticaret Sitesi kurduk 3
ortak Bayağı da para yatırdık yani
yatırdık sonra da batırdık aynı 8 Aynı
hızla üç buçuk seneye gece gündüz böyle
Nefes almadan Çünkü e-ticaret demek 24
saat açık dükkanın vardır yani herhangi
bir sorun çıkabilir böyle tetikte
olmalısın arkadaşlar çok uğraştın Yani
gece mi gündüz mü verdim fakat elinizde
Bu tecrübeden bir CD kaldı Sadece hem de
büyük bir para kaybı kaldı Bazı
tecrübeler çok pahalı öğreniyor bir
pahalı tecrübem oldu Elimde
bir sene Bunalım yaşadım öyle yerler
değil Çünkü ben çalışmayı çok seven asla
duramayan hiperaktif bir insanın Ya ne
yapacağım yani ben şimdi işim yok ve
bütün kahve migren Ben ne yapacağım bir
sene böyle bunalımın en dibini vurdum
böyle Sonra dedim ki hayır ben ben
evdeyim ya biz seni evde kaldım ya çok
yemek yaptığımı devam misafir var Yemek
yapıyorum değil yemekler sunumlar yeni
şeyler reçeteler falan o Sen de
Babaannem vefat etti benim babaanne
tarafı yani Baba tarafı Sivaslı ürünü
anne tarafında girip İlhan yılı Hadi
anne tarafında böyle acayip maddeler
Otlar çok iki tarafta müthiş Mutfağı
meraklı Baba tarafında da içli köfteler
dolmalar işte böyle daha Anadolu
yemekleri ve böyle bir taraf daha
babaerkil işte erkekler için mutfağa
girmez hep kadınlar çalışır bir taraf
daha modern kadınlı erkekli mutfağa
girer ve mutfakta her zaman müzik
değildir bir mutfağa düşünün yemek
yapıyorum Bir yandan da hep kasıl
açıktır şarkılar söylersiniz dolma
sararken O yüzden Demek ki bende bu
birikmiş ve ben dedim ki ben Babaannem
vefat etti Böyle mutfak eşyaları geldi
bana dedi ki ben babaannemin
reçetelerine ortaya koyacağım tekrardan
çıkartacağım bunları yazılı hale
getireceğim Anneannemden annemden
başladım yemek yapmaya yemek yaptım ve
bir ekip kurdum üç tane bugüne kadar hiç
çalışmamış bayağı bir de şoförümüz vardı
evde ev yemekleri takmaya başladım ya da
bu akşam evde bir etli dolma olsa
hepinizin Hoşuna gitmez mi kim oturup
soracaktım ve Çünkü vakit yok hani böyle
ince işle oyunda oyalı mutfak koydum
ismine ince işte yemekler yapmaya
başladı ekip süper bir anda yani bir
sene içinde Ata Bir buçuk sene içinde
böyle yüz kişilik yemek çıkıyor ufacık
mutfaktan çıkıyor bunlar ama oluyor yani
bir şekilde daha büyümeye başladım oyalı
mutfağında korkuyordum Çünkü Anneme
teşekkür de annemin ismi o ya hani Annem
öğretti bana her şeyi o yüzden biz
erkekte olsan kız da olsa yemeye genelde
halinde bu kısıma bir teşekkürdür oyalı
mutfak Aynı zamanda da o ya ince işlemi
yani Eskiden kadınlar
oyalarla anlatılmış dertlerini ne demek
istiyorum mesela Ve tabii ki WhatsApp
yok mesaj yok Emoji yok İmaj ile
anlıyoruz şimdi kimin durumunu herkes
kahkaha atıyor Çok mutlu bir imaj ile
her şeyi çözüyoruz o zaman ne yaparlar
çıkıyor musunuz bahçeye çıktı acı biber
oyasına bağladı başına hocamla
kavgalıyım ya da kayınvalidemle
kavgalıyım demek Gelen geçen komşular
ama bugün kavgalı diye bilirlermiş ya da
morsümbül takan nişanlıyım evliyim bütün
askerde eşim var Yani bunların hepsi
oyalarla veririz o yüzden oyala mutfakta
isim olarak kaldı şimdi Neyse bu işi
artık İyi gidiyor tamam dedim ki evden
çıkıyorum ben kendim atölye açacağım hem
eğitim veririm hem buradan satış yaparım
diye bir telefon çaldı 360 TV'den
Aradılar beni Açelya Akkoyun programına
çağırdılar
bu programa çay yeter canlı yayın
Tamam gelirim dedim kapattım o anda
böyle bir elma yuttum bütün olarak böyle
karın ağrısı canlı yayında hayatımda hiç
televizyona çıkmışım yani canlı yayın ne
demek İlk başta
bir hafta o elmayı ankit midem
sindiremedigi bilgisi ancak öyle
anlatabiliyorum takip ve böyle
anlatabilirim neyse gittim orada çok
yaptın Pir keyif alt Allah o tiyatro
sahne Hani o en başa dönelim Mutfağı
zaten çok keyif yapıyor kendimi
unutuyorum sahne Aman Allahım sana
bebeğim yani mi hiçbir şey ikisi
birleştimi kucağıma geldi mi mi müthiş
Keyif yapıyor yani hiç çıktım yayından
illaki ya Özcan çok güzel geçti 15 günde
bir gelir misiniz Sırlar gelirim dedim
Tabii ki yani ben Çok keyif aldım bende
15 gün biraz gel bu kanallarında
Oradalar Ben telefonlar geliyor
olamıyorum ne oluyor yani ne değişti
hayatında sonra üç ay sonra 360 TV den
kendi programımı yapma teklifi almadım
Yani gidelim mucize kendi programı ben
tek başıma her gün hafta içi her gün
iki tane tarif yapacağım
Çok güzel böyle bir botlar dönüyor abi
Bakayım üstüne dökme Ayça Kaya uyu
burada Aksak Özge çanta Bu da bir işim
var benim yani ben nasıl oldu da bu
sevgilim inanın kendime inanamadım sonra
tabii ki çok tecrübe lendim aldığım her
program teklifi beni böyle başka bir
yere taşıdı çok zevk alıyorum Çok keyif
alıyorum Her canlı yayın benim için
müthiş bir şey Geçen sene de Ender Saraç
Dr Ender Saraç'la birlikte Show TV dedim
her sabah saat beş buçukta kalkıp böyle
keyifle gittim hala şu anda Bu bir
çıkıyorum Osman Müftüoğlu ile çarşamba
günleri YouTube kanalım var evimi bu
sene Talat yapıp mutfağını sahnem yaptı
görmeniz lazım bildiğiniz bir stüdyom
var Işıl ışıl ve orada YouTube çekiyorum
Yani aslında mutfak labratuar gibi benim
için yeni tarifler geliştiriyorum tarih
geliştirici sebzelere bayılıyorum Benim
yüzümden mi sayemde mi bilmiyorum ama
Oğlum ben 18 yaşında vegan oldu yani
böyle bir karar da karşıma çıktı biraz
insanları yönlendiriyorum sağlıklı
beslenmeyi Bu da çok hoşuma gidiyor
istemiyor yani bu da farkında olmadan
yapıyorsunuz ama Merkez mesajlar
yaptığınız yemekler bir yerlere
dokunuyor çok güzel Takipçilerim olduğu
insanlardan harika geri dönüşler gibi
Bunların hepsi benim için bir mucize
sonra düşündüm baktım Evet yemek hep
ilgi alanımda hep hobim de yaptığı aşkım
da belki yapıyordu değilim ben böyle bir
yeter bu ama sahnede olmayı çok
seviyorum Hani o yüzden bu da birleşti
kucağıma geldi böyle hediye paketi gibi
bilemiyorum şu anda size heyecanlandıran
bu yaşlarda Mesela benim siyah Trolü
sevdiğim gibi öyle bir şey var mı
İçinizde Hani Burada şimdi her konuşmayı
geldi içinizdeki o Tutku dedi değil mi
Hani bunu çok duyuyoruz Eskiden
ailelerine derdi doktor olacaksın bitti
yani evde olmuş şimdi Tıp Of ya da
mesela doktor olacaksın diye bir de
diridirler mühendis olacaksın ibret
şimdi aileler bilecek ki dur Dur
içindekine bir bak hani sen de Muhakkak
bir şey değil seviyorsan onu yap hani
Herkes ona dönüyor Çünkü ben mesela şu
an mutfakta bir kelebek gibi hiçbir şey
bana zor gelmiyor ya da sahneye
çıktığımda ya da canlı yayına herkes onu
nasıl yapıyorsun ya O kadar keyifle
yapıyorum yani Keşke yerimde olsanız o
mutlu Siz Yaşasın O yüzden biraz böyle
acele etmeyin eminim bir şey Siz de
böyle bir gün tek o içinizdeki o dediğim
gibi hayal ver böyle bir yok kucağınıza
düşecek Ben kesinlikle inanıyorum
benim böyle kısaca
yaşadıklarım bunlardı size paylaşmak çok
keyifliydi
beni Umarım bir yerde karşılaşırız Belki
bir videoda karşılaşırız dersiniz ki
işte Özge bizi anlattım işte ne kadar
keyif aldığımı dersiniz Benim de macera
böyle bir gün hayallerinizi kavuşmanız
dileğiyle
konuşmam nokta alacağım Ama şunu da
söyleyeceğim Hani iş hayatı Uzun Bir Yol
Sizi orada bakma ben 40 yaşında buldum
dedim yani hiçbir şey için geçtiği ama
böyle mutsuz işe giden insanlara her
zaman böyle içimde bir üzüntü oluyor
benim hani bu kadar çalışma bu kadar
emek ama Mutsuzsun işyerinde işte bunu
kırmak için umutsuzluk Daha yaratıcı
olmak için İçindeki sesi biraz
dinlemenizi tavsiye ediyorum Tekrar çok
teşekkür ederim ben burada olmaktan Çok
keyif aldım
Sağolun davet ettiğini Küçük Ağa